it worked oh my god okay the one good
thing to come out of this freaking
disaster
hey guys it's kelly i'm back again and
i've been challenged to make a
restaurant quality meal that
normally takes two hours in under 20
minutes
first up for my appetizer i'm making a
vegan coconut city chip
for my main course i'm making fried fish
tacos with a creamy slaw
and a charred jalapeno crema and for
dessert i'm making a choco flan this is
the star of the show because normally it
takes two hours to make but with a few
hacks and tricks
i'm going to show you how to make it in
under 20 minutes all right guys i'm
nervous
i'm sweating but there's only one way to
get through this and that is to start
all right start the clock let's go okay
first up
i'm going to turn on the oil because we
are deep frying
now i'm making the chocolate flan that i
talked about i don't
i don't know if this is going to work
normally you have to bake
this for like an hour and it has to sit
for an hour
in the fridge to like harden back up but
i mean we're going to try it we're going
to see what happens
and it could fall right when i unmold it
forget oh half of it so another hack i'm
doing
is using a box mix normally you would
make
chocolate cake from scratch but i don't
have time for that so
box mix edit normally chocolate wine
takes
an hour to bake hour plus and then an
hour
to sit in the fridge to cool to harden
back up we're going to add a little
cinnamon because why not
next i'm making the custard because this
is a layered plan there's like a layer
of chocolate
and then there's a layer of flan which
is basically custard
it looks really cool and then there's a
caramel layer as well
so we got eggs sweet and condensed milk
funny story i never use sweetened
condensed milk and still i started
working at tasty i
swear if you work at tasty you have to
become very
familiar with sweetened smell
vanilla and then a cup of milk
i'm kind of losing some flavor with
these hacks because i'm using a box mix
and i'm not making the caramel from
scratch i'm using jarred
[Music]
okay you just want to blend that lightly
because you don't want to get a ton of
air in there your flan will be
i don't know not as good okay so now i'm
just
liberally liberally spraying a silicone
mini bundt pan and pouring some
store-bought caramel
in the bottom and now i'm going to layer
some of our cake
normally you like want to take your time
with this so to make pretty edges so it
doesn't go everywhere but
guys i don't i don't have that luxury
there's a lot of
one it could not cook and it would just
fall over two
the layers could not separate and it
would just be like one combined
ugly mess okay so i'm putting it in my
instant pot
and then i'm gonna gently pour this flan
on top and it's gonna go to the bottom
and that is okay
i can already tell it's not gonna be
pretty pressure cook
one minute it's going in the pressure
cooker for 11 minutes
and you guys know my record with the
pressure cooker
okay it's working we'll see how long it
takes to come to temp
next up we need to char a jalapeno this
is for my charred jalapeno
crema putting it cut side down on a
sheet tray and i'm going to let it
broil until it is browned on the edges
and just gives your crema a little more
flavor let's get to the hard part
we have to make coconut ceviche and in
order to do that i have to open
two coconuts so ready here we go
okay whoa oh god
okay we're letting all that water out
oh god okay
okay i do one more here we go
sorry coconut i feel like i'm butchering
it
okay so now that we have our coconuts
open
i have to cut out this meat this is a
young coconut so it's flesh is
soft guys don't be scared
see this is why i said
get some aggression out
sorry guys sorry
one and i gotta do another oh god
this should be the thought
okay this that doesn't look great so now
i'm going to take a spoon and
just take it along the edge kind of like
how you would scoop out an avocado
and just scoop it out and then this is
going to be the base of the ceviche so
instead of using raw fish
we're going to use the soft flesh of the
coconut it really almost tastes like
scallops
or like calamari it's pretty good can
somebody give me my time
i've told me his life holy [ __ ] oh my
god okay
are you serious oh the pressure is on
but i knew that
before remember i said i was sweating oh
my god that's as good as that's getting
so
normally if i had time i would like run
this under cold water to kind of remove
all the bits
but i don't have a lot of time so i'm
just gonna have to
dunk it in some cold water so now i'm
just dicing up my coconut meat
and hoping all is well in the world
this is not a lot of coconut guys oh my
god like i would have been done if i
just did scallops
but no i had to challenge myself
that was dumb i still have to fry fish i
have to make slaw i have to make
charred jalapeno crema is my thing up to
pressure
oh okay well i didn't even hear that
beet because i was in coconut
world but you know what that's gonna
have to do i hope everybody just wants a
bite of ceviche because that's all
they're getting
and let's check this those are not
broiled
let's check our oil temp oh god it's
over time
okay i don't even know what i'm doing i
just grabbed an onion it felt right
so that's the next step i guess
next up i don't know rip this open
like hulk hogan the fried tostada
because if you're not getting a lot of
ceviche i might as well give you like a
nice
fried tortilla i got to do something to
make it up right next up i am making
fried fish i'm making a batter a little
flour a little cornstarch
where's the baking powder oh no oh okay
okay i'm not taking any shortcuts for
the fish this is just like a traditional
beer battered recipe
but i just list with two whisks
and now i'm adding some beer you're
supposed to add three-fourths cup but
i don't have time to measure so i'm just
going to
sorry back to these okay this makes up
for the ceviche right
okay more beer more always more beer
maybe i should just drink the beer
and i would feel better time what's my
time
oh my god okay these are coming out
let's add a few more
no no ma'am no
but you know i'm gonna try i'm gonna try
let's get to a little mayonnaise if i
remember
right now i'm making my creamy lime slaw
and we're just gonna do some of this red
onion
some fresh cilantro some salt did i
already add this i
i don't remember and some lime juice
okay oh these are juicy
i like that i got five minutes okay
that looks great luckily first takes two
minutes to fry
red onion goes in the ceviche you need
to make
crema some people commented in the last
videos asking if i had
fingertips and the answer is no i don't
anymore they're gone okay so i had some
cilantro some more lime
i think i'm supposed to put garlic in
here yep i'm behind
i i i just i knew this was gonna happen
this is not well for me
okay we're gonna let that go take these
out
this is a mess oh my god okay that's
done
let's make our sauce for
this whatever this is if i can remember
okay cilantro
some of that coconut water that came out
of the coconut
this is the sauce for the ceviche
so another guard glow okay
oh my god i was supposed to add avocado
to that oh shoot
time
oh my god okay the fish isn't even in
how could it be 252
because that hasn't even i think this is
a setup okay okay
i don't even remember what goes in that
i i don't remember
okay so now i'm counting now i'm cutting
the fish
in like a fish stick okay you're getting
a fish tick taco basically
and i hope you like it okay i'm adding
it to my batter
adding it to my file i have no idea what
temperature this is because
there's just no time to even check
this this isn't happening i shouldn't
have done the tostada but i was trying
to make up for everything
okay okay almost killed myself there
but worth it worth it for this
taco i think i need more water well okay
oh my god
it's not blending okay i mean what's the
point of resting
seeing the recipes i don't have time
oh my gosh okay three's getting a taco
one taco
each let's even check this
oh my god ah
i didn't do it i am so pissed off for
the ceviche i probably needed about two
more minutes
my fish was done so i just needed to
plate it probably like a minute
and the dessert is done i heard it go
off before the 20-minute timer
but i couldn't get to it okay tell me
the truth
it worked oh my god okay the one good
thing to come out of this freaking
disaster
hold on let me just let me just have
some of this
first i'm gonna try the ceviche
this is really refreshing it's light the
only thing i messed up was i didn't
check the seasoning it could have been a
little saltier but it is still really
delicious
next up tacos is that crunch that's a
pretty game to taco these are really
amazing
the fish is super crunchy on the outside
and tender on the inside it's flavorful
it's really good this is what i've been
waiting for this looks incredible
i think this dessert makes up for me not
finishing anytime it is
definitely the best thing that came out
of my day
this is amazing the cinnamon i added to
the cake pairs really well with the
caramel and the flan
and it took me 20 minutes all right guys
thank you so much for watching
stay tuned for more episodes of tasty's
20-minute meal challenge
until then i'll see you later oh yes
you